okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
happy to try and answer questions
specific and general about uh either
recent history that I've been involved
in or history from the past that I might
have studied
um
let's see
uh
um
as a question from Aaron here did I mean
I'm afraid I don't know the answer to
that any ancient unit systems number
systems use base 10 or did they all use
more easily divisible bases like 12 2016
and so on so the thing you have to
understand about about
um the representation of numbers is that
uh
well you know the idea of positional
notation that we have today that's the
Hindu Arabic number system
um is something that well it came to the
West around 1200 uh particularly through
the work of Fibonacci
um
uh and um
the uh his book Lieber abachi the book
of the Abacus which kind of promoted uh
Hindu Arabic positional notation type
numbers as the uh as the kind of um the
Magic Bullet for merchants and so on
trying to work out how to do their
computations
but
there were very different kinds of
number systems like for example the
Roman number system is one where well a
sort of is a base I mean it's it's kind
of base 10
um but it has you know some base five
pieces that x's and v's and their C's
and M's and D's and so on in the number
system so it's kind of a complicated
mixed Radix system now for example the
Greek number system the interesting
story there in uh that was
um
uh
let's see I mean that there's you know
the the names of the numbers uh yeah I
mean the the the the even in ancient
Greek
um the the certainly the number system
had the name of a of numbers uh you know
such and such Kai Deca you know it's
like like Tetra kydeka I think will be
14.
um is four and ten so that's already a
kind of a base 10 like system but there
were a lot of funkinesses in the actual
notation so for example in in ancient
Greek the ancient Greek number system
they use the letters of their alphabet
as the sequential numbers so Alpha was
One beta was two gamma was three Etc et
cetera et cetera uh is an interesting
you know for somebody like me who's been
interested in things like language
design for a long time the ancient Greek
number system is a good example of a of
a mistake in some respects because what
they did was they they had the letters
of the alphabet in the order of their
alphabet represent numbers but some of
those letters went out of circulation as
letters to be used in text so sampi di
gamma these are things that existed in
the sort of ancient Greek numbers
Ancient Ancient Greek uh alphabet and
those got burnt into their number system
I think sampia is 60 if I remember
correctly
um but sampi is not a word that is not a
letter name usually here you know it's
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Epsilon data
Theta outer Capital mu et cetera et
cetera et cetera the usual Greek letters
you don't hear sample or diagama or
copper those are the three that I think
went out of circulation you know die
gamma is like a w sound copper is like a
a queue like thing so so you know when
people were labeling I'm not sure if by
the time of Euclid I think it had
already gone out of circulation and so
when Euclid had to label uh uh geometric
diagrams and it's an interesting thing
that Euclid did have geometric diagrams
that got labeled and he would use you
know Alpha Beta data and so on to
represent magnitudes of angles and
things like that and you know if you've
got three angles to indicate you might
use Alpha Beta gamma
um you might use some or if you might if
you wanted to use p q r the
corresponding letters you know Greek
letters will be Pi copper row so to
speak
um but um and um
uh let's see diagrama
hmm what is the sound for diagrammer uh
I think yeah guy gamma is a
W like thing
um sampi is this you know is is I'm not
sure what sound that makes but any case
in the in the Greek number system what
they did was they had uh they didn't
really have positional notation like
when they had the number 60 they had a
letter that represented 60 and they
appended to that letter it might be you
know sampi beta might be 62 if I
remember correctly but it's not like you
were using uh the positional number you
know whatever it is alphabetic Gamma
Delta Epsilon Zeta so it would be it
would have been Zeta beta if it had been
a positional notation but actually the
thing that represented the 60 was a
different letter from the thing that was
representing a six but moved into the
other position
so so I think the answer is yes there
were ancient number systems that were
base 10 uh the Babylonian system from
which we get our hours minute seconds
and so on was a base 60 system
um and uh that was um
uh that was that was that particular uh
way of doing things but that wasn't the
universal thing and I guess I guess
people have had you know 10 fingers for
a long time and that's been a convenient
way to do counting for a long time in
fact I I'm not even I think it might be
the case that the tally marks which are
some of the earliest number
representations that we have where
you're just marking on a bone or
something you're just marking uh you
know tally marks to indicate things I I
think this notation of putting a slash
through five of them I think that's
pretty ancient
um and so that that would be another
example there
um
let's see
oh there's a question here from Mikhail
what is the history of design patterns
and software engineering how did people
come to them
well
let's talk a little bit about the
history of of programming languages and
um
uh the general way that one sort of
specifies software so I guess it began
in the mid to late 1950s
with
kind of the arrival of somewhat
standardized computers I mean the very
first computers like the Antioch and so
on from the mid-1940s had been mid to
late 1940s had been kind of one of the
top kind machines and there was sort of
increasing standardization with what
were the companies Burrows univac
uh and IBM was a big player
um by uh I would say in the mid to late
50s there were things like the early
sort of standardized IBM maybe the 709
if I remember correctly predecessor of
the IBM 360 which was sort of the big
sort of Workhorse Mainframe computer
that arrived in the early 1960s but as
these computers that were somewhat more
standardized kind of came into existence
so there was a desire to have somewhat
more standardized kind of programming
mechanisms and it wasn't the case that
oh you are using the such and such you
know the iliac one computer or something
so this is how you program it and if
you're using the some other computer
this is how you program it it was
there's a sort of standardized way of
doing it and so I think the the early
um there were a variety of early
languages I think there was a thing
called auto code which I know a little
about the first one that I know anything
significant about is Fortran uh Fortran
was a was I think pretty IBM connected
if I remember correctly
um Fortran the the name meant formula
translation and so the idea was that you
would be able to write a mathematical
type formula that with things like X
Plus y times Z or something with you
know the letter the plus signs and the
stars and so on to indicate those
operations and that that formula would
get translated into the machine code of
the the computer and I think Grace
Hopper was the person who I
if I'm remembering correctly was the the
leader of that um that effort to make
fortune if I remember correctly
um
and uh the the early
uh so so you know the big emphasis was
can you take something which is sort of
a a naturally written mathy formula and
translated into the machine code of the
computer
and there were things about the machine
that were oh like for example what would
it print out or it would print these you
could print out a string of data and so
there was a uh Fortran format statements
which where you would say oh I want to
just print this number out and
um the uh for example one of the things
that was kind of an awkward thing was
printing a string like the result is and
then just the number you know you could
print the number out that was a
well-defined way to do that uh in the
one of the issues was that there was a
desire to sort of specify how wide the
thing you printed out was going to be
and so the number will be six digits or
whatever it was and there will be a way
of specifying the format for the number
then the way of specifying the string
was the so-called Hollerith codes so you
would say things like 13h and then you
would give the string you were going to
specify I guess people hadn't figured
out delimiters for Strings the idea of
quotes around strings to indicate where
does the string start where does the
string end that wasn't a thing at that
point so in early Fortran even fortrans
that I used in the 1970s uh mid-1970s
um it was still the case you would say
13h or something which means there are
13 characters that are coming in this
string those are what you're going to
include in the output H the Hollerith
name was in in Num uh in in kind of
recognition of Hermann Hollow Earth who
had been one of the early people
um and the origination of IBM in the
early 1900s
um when it was the kind of a Hollerith
tabulating machine had been the thing
used for the Census Bureau in the U.S uh
where they were using kind of cards
um as a way to tabulate
um kind of Senseless results you would
get a card and you know you would have
punch holes in it and you would you
would be able to sort of run a
um some kind of Rod through the place
where there were those holes punched and
that was the way of representing you
know how many people were and you would
pick up the cards and the ones that sort
of came out with the with the with the
Rod that you put through were the ones
that included that particular hole that
was punched and so on I mean this whole
technology of cards was quite old I mean
this had been invented by Jacquard so
the Jacquard Loom around 1800 as a way
of specifying kind of weaving patterns
for looms and That Was Then used for
tabulation early 1900 ish by what became
IBM and then that was the thing that
became what was used as the principal
way of programming large computers was
card decks big stacks of these cards
um that uh were um
uh
my gosh I'm forgetting I you know I I
you used to use these on card punches
and the way it would work is you would
be typing typing typing and you would be
and then you would uh uh and and that
would be uh sort of punching holes and
successive columns on the card and for
example if you're if your line of code
and your Fortran program for example ran
too long you would uh go on to another
card and you would punch out something
in the continuation column because I
think column six but I can't remember
for sure
um of an 80 column card
um that would be the indication that
this was a continuation card from uh
from what would be um from the previous
card and of course the the thing that
was always the horror was you would have
these card decks might be a big thick
stack of cards and the the real horror
would be if you drop the card deck and
you've randomized the collection of
cards and then I think one of the one of
the sort of technologies that came in
was somehow numbering those cards when
they got generated so that you could uh
so that a machine could automatically
Resort them into order fortunately I
don't I don't recall ever dropping a
card deck but you would tend to put them
you know the typical way of using a
Mainframe computer certainly the first
ones I used
um uh was uh there would be these um uh
there would be these operators would be
the people actually enabled to be you
know the the high priests you know
enabled to actually be with the computer
and
um they you would put you know in these
wooden pigeon holes you would put your
card deck in there and I I think you
usually put a rubber band or something
around it
um and uh then
we put it in there some mysterious uh it
feels very delphic you know it's like
the delphic Oracle or something you're
you're putting things through slots and
then the machine is running your code
and then you know somebody would sort of
take the card deck and then uh half an
hour an hour later or something you'd
come back and there would be a a folded
line printer output in your pigeonhole
along with your cards again
um so somebody would have run the
program and then uh you know given you
the results back I have to say when I
was um
um when I was this was probably 1977 was
the first time I was actually sort of uh
in the room with the Mainframe computer
I worked at Argonne National Lab near
Chicago for a for a summer in 1977 and
that was a place where they they trusted
the the um the physicists or whatever or
the uh the the sort of young
protophysicists like me to actually be
in the room with this expensive
mainframe computers where you could
actually you know interact with it
directly so to speak rather than handing
it to the um to the high priests or
whatever
um and I suppose also
um gosh it's a long time since I thought
about this but um I worked the year
before that in 1976 I worked at the
Rutherford lab in England which is part
of the um
well it was um uh part of the nuclear
physics and particle physics research uh
apparatus in the UK and the Rutherford
lab they had actually were developing a
a time sharing system for some reason I
think it was called Tas time sharing
um system and that had uh displays where
you could interactively uh do things at
least you could interactively submit
jobs for the computer and so on
um those were that was still the time
when when computer terminals there were
obviously cathode ray tubes but they
were called vdus visual display units
um as the uh the thing that was I I
guess terminal may have been an American
word which gradually got to sort of
exported around the world I mean a
number of these computer terms
um were different in for example the UK
and the US like for example
um the uh the term for memory in the U.S
is storage or store
um in the in the UK earliest it was I'm
sure it's now memory
um and and for example I remember uh the
concept of booting a computer was a very
was definitely not a British Computing
terminology thing when we talk about
running the initial instructions as
opposed to booting a computer
um but any case but I I digress talking
about the history of programming
languages so I think it was 1958 was the
um origination of Fortran around the
same time was Cobalt
um and uh Kobo was intended as a
business language and it was sort of
intended to be if Fortran was take math
notation and put it on the computer uh
Cobalt was take English language and put
it on the computer and make things be
like pseudo English statements
um so
both of those in Fortran the style of
writing code was uh some aspects of it
are painfully similar to today's uh
modern traditional programming languages
I mean Fortran was very much into uh
well okay Fortran did not have recursion
you couldn't have one function that
called another function repeatedly uh
Fortran was it had its means of control
flow was a lot of go-to's if blah blah
blah go to instructions such and such or
go to labels such and such
um in terms of modernization of code
Fortran did have early fortrans Fortran
66 for example from 1966 that was a
Fortran that I used for example
um had uh
um had the notion of of uh subroutines
that you would call
um the term function was a little bit
more more recent but subroutines
that would be the things that would be a
block of code and so on and there would
be local variables in those subroutines
and there would be Global variables and
one of the horrors of large Fortran
programs were these things called common
blocks
where you would basically define global
storage for your for your program and
you would name these pieces of the
common block and you would basically be
able to access these sort of global
variables across different parts of your
program and things got often very
spaghettified in doing that
but um
I would say that the uh sort of the
attempt to make sort of a principled
um early languages uh Fortran was very
much a practical sort of engineering
oriented language
um COBOL Business Systems language there
was an effort I think started in 1957 58
or so to make this language called algol
which will be a more principled kind of
more theoretically based language and
there was sort of a big Committee of
people that uh got involved in doing
that it was the place where these sort
of formal specifications Bacchus now are
forms formal kind of parser
specifications were kind of a a big
thing algol got very overblown and its
specification was never implemented in
full it was sort of a stimulus for for
future programming languages but it
never was fully implemented
um this to my knowledge
um there were versions of it there were
sort of spin-offs like I remember I
um uh well I didn't like it very much
but I briefly was exposed to a language
called Saint Paul which was a simple
version of algol that was I was exposed
to around 1972 or so
um and but but you know to be clear even
in the 1970s early 1970s serious
programmers wrote an Assembly Language
serious programmers writing systems
level code did not imagine that they
would write in a quote's high-level
language even at the level of something
like Fortran
but you know the next kind of really big
thing that came on the scene well a
language called Pascal uh developed by a
person called Nicholas worth in
Switzerland
um Pascal was kind of a a um I would say
a cleaner and more principled language
there were also a series of other
languages there was language called bcpl
um I don't remember what BC stood for it
I think originated in London University
um the uh uh and that there was sort of
a version of that sort of a spin-off
from that called B and then famously the
next spin-off from that was called C and
that became the C programming language
and I think that the um
the the thing to understand is some of
the programs when people writing big
application programs they were usually
writing it in things like IBM 360
Assembly Language every separate
computer had a different Assembly
Language and that would be kind of a
lock-in for you know for application
programs oh they were for IBM mainframes
and that was all they were for because
that was the only thing that that
instruction set worked with and I think
just as has happened with
microprocessors there was an effort to
clone the instruction set and I as I
recall there was a big sort of antitrust
Showdown about cloning instruction sets
for mainframe computers uh and obviously
the issue there is whether the
application software is locked to a
particular Mainframe computer then this
was sort of a thing that played out in
the 1960s early 1970s
but in any case the um the thing that
then happened in terms of of programming
languages you know serious stuff was
written in Los Angeles language then
there were starting to be things that
were written in other languages
um the uh I think the original Mac
operating system was written in Pascal
um and famously uh the C programming
language was developed at Bell labs to
write the Unix operating system
so there have been an operating system
called multix which was an earlier quite
quite big operating system I should have
explained that
one of the things that happened in the
computer industry was you know IBM was
sort of the big player with its big
machines then digital Equipment
Corporation came along this is now on
the 1960s and uh came along with its PDP
series of computers starting with PDP
one
um and these were kind of smaller
computers that were still serious
computers and uh for example the um uh
by the time it was the PDP 10 PDP 10 was
a pretty serious computer uh it was a
computer I used quite extensively
um it was a computer actually available
over the Opera net
um by the mid-1970s that was sort of a a
serious Contender for a sort of research
oriented computer
um and that was um the PDP 10
ran the multix operating system as I
recall uh and um the um uh which I
assume was written in the summary
language
um Unix was a kind of
um uh you know um you know stripped down
multix that was its original concept and
it for its creation a new language was
created the C programming language and
that was basically Dennis Ritchie and um
uh Ken Thompson who were The Originators
of um
um the um
uh these uh these languages that
somebody's asking did I meet these
people yes I certainly met Dennis
Ritchie uh Brian cunnaghan who came on
the scene a bit later Ken Thompson was
the was the originator I think of the
sort of operating system
um and and see story
um
uh I never met Nicholas worth
unfortunately
um Alan K I have met yes
um
and uh
Paul Alan I don't believe I ever met
um
the Nicholas yeah so so Dennis Ritchie
actually sort of interesting background
uh he had written his PhD thesis about
sort of theoretical computation and
particularly these things called
register machines which are sort of
simple idealizations of computation
and um in developing the C programming
language one of the things that was sort
of nice about see was this very minimal
approach to everything very minimalist
kind of um uh way of presenting things
and I think maybe that was a little bit
of a spin-off of Dennis Ritchie's
earlier work on on things like register
machines but um uh that was um one the
the original machine I believe the
pdp-11 which was a small computer was um
the original thing on which the uh the C
programming language was originated
although I I the the purpose
of C was to develop the Unix operating
system the Unix operating system's
original purpose was to run telephones
switches for the for the Bell System for
for at T and I I was briefly a
consultant in the uh at Bell labs and uh
sort of interacted a bunch with the the
Unix group that was in
1983-ish time frame
um I had so that's um and at the time
there were uh the whole series of
computers that have been constructed for
by the Bell System to run phone
exchanges and they were running I think
a version of Unix called Unix RT a
real-time version of Unix where you know
to my early Amusement so to speak there
were these system calls that were things
like you know initiate a trunk phone
call and so on those were sort of part
of the operating system but the thing
that happened with with Unix among other
things was that Bell Labs didn't really
you know they had developed it for the
purpose of running phone switches and
any other use of it was like well
whatever you know we can just give it
away and that was an important sort of
stimulus was Bell Labs at T was just
sort of letting the Unix operating
system be used elsewhere and a bunch of
of companies started using Unix on their
computers and that was sort of a big
theme of some of the for example early
workstation computers is now 1980s
um was running Unix they didn't all run
Unix they some of them ran other kinds
of things and and there were even
attempts to make a a non-bell Labs
entangled Unix the thing called coherent
which was an attempt to to make from
scratch a um uh a version that didn't
have the licensing issues that that the
Bell Labs Unix had but any case that
we're sort of skipping ahead in terms of
programming languages because C was sort
of a a clean programming language I
think you know Pascal like C had had
sort of nice encapsulated of functions
they'd had recursion it had all those
kinds of things
it still had uh you know all those
languages had you know go-to's and
labels and things like this they all had
basically the same set of operations I
mean conditionals function calls uh you
know transfer control by by go-to's
things like that they all were the same
kind of stuff and um they started to
have I mean c I guess uh I think maybe
Pascal has this as well has the kind of
struct data structure type you know
build a more complicated thing
um that you can encapsulate in a single
variable see had a particularly clean
way of dealing with pointers has a
particularly clean way of dealing with
pointers uh pointers to memory you know
memory references and things like that
but so that was kind of the um uh let's
see the the early history of those
things now there were others some other
entrants like for example basic was the
thing that appeared on the scene that
had been developed at Dartmouth by um
John kameny
um who was again a very much a a sort of
theoretical mathematical logic kind of
person who I think Rose to be the
president of Dartmouth College and who
was big on sort of uh trying to this is
1960s on sort of introducing this idea
of computing into uh uh you know into
um into things at large and I I see
basic as being sort of the first to
probably five waves of let's Teach the
World coding
um it's probably one of the better ones
actually uh and they've all been you
know they've gone in sequence I I mean
I'm afraid I would say that uh you know
one of the challenges is when you don't
have you know in with wolf and language
in our computational language as soon as
you're writing code you can write it
about things but because the language
actually knows about the world it knows
about you know cities and and planets
and it knows about all these different
algorithms and graphics and audio and
all that kind of thing so it's very easy
to start actually doing computation
about things but when you're dealing
with a raw programming language who's
real objective is just tell that
computer how to you know move its bits
around it tends to get rather rather dry
rather quickly and uh there's sort of
and that's been a kind of a a curse of
people trying to sort of teach coding to
the world is well you know what are you
going to code about I mean it's kind of
It kind of reminds one back in ancient
Babylon though with these scribal
schools where scribes were learning to
write and you know yes you learn to
write but then a large part of sort of
the scribal school was learning about
different topics that you could then be
writing about so to speak but I think
you know in some of these efforts to
let's teach coding with low-level
languages it's kind of uh you know what
what they might have called themselves
high-level languages but I call them
low-level languages they're not full
computational languages they're just
programming languages
um it's you know you kind of run out of
things to program about rather quickly
uh which is something that you know with
our kind of computational language story
the great thing is that you actually get
to write code you get to sort of present
things computationally about all these
different things in the world and that
gives you a lot of sort of mileage gives
you a lot of potential to actually teach
in an interesting way about these things
but anyway basic was an early entrant in
um uh in in sort of the the story of um
of programming languages it was clean it
was simple uh it was quite unstructured
um but it was uh you know it was it was
a good thing and basically got a big
boost when Bill Gates kind of um uh you
know start started making versions of it
for early personal computers and so on
and just as Pascal had gotten quite a
boost when it was uh well let's see it
was particularly the company called
Borland and Philippe Khan and so on had
developed a um
I'm forgetting this history there was a
thing called UCSD Pascal that somehow
showed up and there was a thing called P
code which was a a kind of a run time
for Pascal that somehow started showing
up on early personal computers
um it didn't quite make it partly
because sort of the there was this kind
of Ballin versus Microsoft Showdown
where Microsoft was kind of on the high
end of of pricing of software bollum was
on kind of the everything costs 100 or
less and and Microsoft won out in that
and so I think the Borland uh you know
Pascal and they were also into a
language called Delphi
um that kind of uh that that lost out in
that story but I think the um
uh the question was about sort of design
patterns and programming languages so by
the time you know one's got to see one
has recursion one has structs one has
pointers
um the the next sort of big thing I
suppose was the story of object oriented
programming and um there was some other
entrance in the programming language
World there have been lisp which was
done by John McCarthy late 1950s
originally as a more theoretical kind of
thing
um and lisp kind of really had a hard
time becoming practical and uh you know
back in the early 1980s there were a
couple of companies that were trying to
make list machines because on sort of a
general purpose computer you couldn't
really have uh sort of the full lisp
story with all of its kind of uh sort of
profligate use of memory and things like
this wasn't something that was uh sort
of readily usable for the things people
imagined they would use it for just
couldn't get the efficiency and remember
people were still a lot programming in
Assembly Language at that time
um and you know I think if history had
had played differently lisp might have
been a a bigger force in the development
of programming languages really wasn't
much of a force
um the uh another thing that originated
was small talk I never used small talk I
didn't know about it in great detail
that was I think Adele Goldberg was a
person involved in that at Xerox Park
um
and it had been uh something that was uh
built to kind of support the bitmap
display Terminals and the early user
interfaces that were developed at Xerox
Park in the early 1970s I guess early to
mid 1970s
um Small Talk uh I gather was sort of an
early model of object-oriented
programming it was sort of forced into
that picture because when you're putting
up Windows on the screen they're kind of
like objects that you have to sort of
poke at Peak things from you know you
have to poke and Peak with the with the
names in in basic for accessing
individual memory locations kind of
going underneath the hood of um uh of
kind of what what the um uh sort of the
the high level description if you've got
variables and so on they was like memory
location such and such what's there and
things like this
um the uh
the thing that um uh you know once you
were building a Windows system you kind
of had to be dealing with these somewhat
uh you know ironically one might say
opaque objects even though they were
windows that of course were not Windows
you looked through their windows that
you are putting text into and so on
um and I think that was what drove that
kind of object-oriented programming
concept by the way there have been other
languages which had some uh significance
like fourth was a language originally
developed for controlling radio
telescopes was a very minimal
stack-based language
um that sort of had its lineage ended up
with kind of the stack-based approaches
of things like the PostScript page
description language things like this it
was the kind of embedded language
um that I suppose these days has been
taken over by languages like Lua and so
on as sort of the the simple embedded
language type thing but in any case the
from sort of the um
uh
um
the the kind of the object-oriented
programming thing that led to in the
when was this this was
the late 1980s
um
I I'm skipping a few things
so
a big sort of fad was this notion of
structured programming not quite sure
what that really meant but I think it
was don't just have random go-to
statements all over your code you know
having the con you know the program sort
of be running this piece and then
randomly start running another piece it
was more like keep the thing more
modular and know you've got a subroutine
here that's well encapsulated and then
another thing can be run over here one
of the things that was part of that
story was the Ada programming language
uh developed by them for the US defense
department in the early 1980s and the
concept of Ado was oh the defense
department is getting all this code
written in all these different languages
it's very hard to verify we're going to
have this one standardized language that
all kind of contracted defense defense
contract code is going to get written in
but I think it was a very committee uh
developed language and it ended up being
very big just like algo and so on and I
don't think it was ever fully
implemented I'm not sure
um and there were sort of a lot of kind
of uh weirdness where it was like well
we're really going to write it in
Fortran let's say oh a c or something
but we're going to translate it into Ada
uh in some nominal automatic translation
thing so we can deliver it for the
contract even though nobody could ever
read the code but then by the illness
must have been the mid-1980s uh this
idea you know everything became about
object-oriented programming that was
that was the story of everything you
know a decent approach for things to do
with uh things like user interfaces
um not a good approach in my view for
General computational language
um the uh the thing that um and there
were a couple of different sort of
competitors there there was Objective C
um which has sort of got adopted by
Steve Jobs at next
um and uh that was oh my gosh what was
the company called Sandy something or
other oh my gosh what was it it was in
um uh oh forgotten
um anyway that was the company that made
Objective C and then there was C plus
plus made by Bjorn Starstruck who I who
I knew slightly when I was at Bell Labs
um the uh
um
uh and C plus plus was was I think from
very early on viewed as being sort of a
big complicated language
um but uh uh it was sort of the other
sort of contender in the object-oriented
languages World
um I think uh you know there was a time
by the early 1990s it was like
everything's got to be object oriented
you know I have to say one of the things
that uh is always a story of of
programming languages is uh you know how
are you going to structure a big program
well in my view the most important thing
is to have kind of a good functional
design for the program good architecture
for the program and to have sort of
standardized lumps of computational work
so you're not sort of building
everything every time you want to build
some particular sub piece you build it
up from scratch if you have and this has
been the concept of Welcome language for
the last uh well basically I've been
working out for 40 years now
um the the to identify these lumps of
repeated computational work and develop
them in a clean way give them names make
sure they can operate between themselves
and that way you routinely use these
sort of sophisticated lumps of
computational work rather than having to
drop down and rebuild things where you
never build the the things you're
building as well as you would if you
built a standardized version of it
um and so for example one of the things
has been the idea of typed languages
which is something that the idea of
types in in languages has been something
that's existed from the very beginning I
mean it's existed in Fortran for example
um back from the late 1950s and and why
did it exist well because you needed to
know were you going to store that thing
as an integer and uh with the bit
pattern of an integer were you going to
store it as a floating Point number
where you know it's a different bit
pattern that represents the number and
the operations that are being done the
machine code operations that are being
done work differently because they're
dealing with a number that is encoded in
that different way but so this idea of
types was an idea that was a practical
idea of early computers early computer
languages it's an idea that that sort of
has flowed through the modern times
things like C allowed you to start
having these these um uh what you might
call um uh uh uh
um type products what you would in
modern terminological type products
things like structs where you can
combine it's an integer it's a pointer
to a real it's an array of you know
doubles whatever it is
um all sort of packed together in one
thing but you know the origination of
the idea of types was kind of a nod to a
piece of mathematical logic that had
originated in the 1910s
um that was um uh Russell
um
the uh
um uh you know
um this was a a Alfred North Whitehead
uh Bertrand Russell production because
what had happened was
uh there were uh this is sort of the
early days of the of the formalization
of mathematics and so on the sort of
pre-computational computation uh where
kind of the notion was uh you know what
was mathematics you know what was what
what kind of a thing how would you build
up the structure of something that would
be mathematics and got love Fraga in the
1880s and so on
um kind of was really pushing this idea
of let's take logic as the as the
underlying raw material and let's build
math on top of logic and so he kind of
tried to set up definitions that were
purely in terms of logic for things like
you know the numbers and upper integers
and sets and things like this later on
things like sets and you know Russell
famously found this kind of um uh this
bug in fragrance setup uh Paradox kind
of thing
um Russell then uh well okay then then
Cantor
had introduced this idea of set theory
and set theory is okay when you have
finite sets you just got a collection of
things and you can talk about that just
fine but by the time you've got infinite
sets it's a much more difficult thing to
start talking about but that was kind of
really what cancel wanted to be talking
about and you know you then get you know
is the set of all sets a member of
itself
is you know all of these kinds of uh
things that eventually become
paradoxical and what Russell suggested
was in order to get rid of these
paradoxes you could introduce this idea
of types and so instead of being able to
talk about just a set it's a set with
anything in it there will be these types
and you could have these hierarchies of
types and that would allow you to
distinguish these things and prevent
these paradoxes about you know sets that
are members of themselves and things
like this so originally types were born
out of this idea of sort of avoid the
paradoxes certain paradoxes and
mathematical logic
um and and then they were sort of you
know as an engineering matter in the
1950s they were introduced into computer
languages
um the it's only very recently in the
last oh I don't know decade or so that
sort of the formal theory of types has
kind of become a thing in its own right
that has had import and kind of the
thinking about the sort of theoretical
aspects of computation and so on and I
think as kind of gets us off topic but I
mean this is um things like homotopic
type Theory and so on and the uh the um
uh these various programs for thinking
about the foundations of mathematics and
the sort of merge foundations of
mathematics and computation that have
come about and and the idea that there
is a calculus of types that you can
actually sort of describe things in
terms of types
um in the end uh what ends up happening
is people uh that we were sort of
seguing a bit off topic here but but um
uh you know there are there's a whole
kind of um there's a whole world of just
doing things in terms of types and for
example in the compile level of language
that we're developing been developing
for a number of years it's a big
Festival of type analysis and type
computation the big issue is if you know
this thing's going to be an integer or
if you know this thing's going to be an
array of integers you can very
efficiently map that into something that
is executed right down at the level of
machine code instructions but you have
to know you have to be able to prove
that this thing can be oh it's either an
integer or it's a list of three real
numbers or something and this analysis
of types is a complicated thing and you
end up with you know type products type
sums a whole sort of a whole calculus
algebra of types
um and uh you know that there's then you
start worrying about things like the
type of types that the type that
represents all uh you know the type that
is uh you know that is the type that
types are so to speak all those kinds of
things uh rather quickly you get into a
complicated hierarchy of things the
other thing is so-called dependent type
Theory where you're dealing with
um this type is not just defined by oh
it's an integer it's a real but it is
defined by some some property oh it's an
integer that has the property that's
greater than three and less than seven
or it has the property that it satisfies
this uh complicated diaphan sign
equation or something and by the time
you're doing dependent type Theory
you've kind of taken the lid off things
and you're doing Universal computation
and there is sort of no uh you end up
with all the difficulties and all the
undecidability issues of sort of General
computation so it tends to be the case
people say oh you can figure out things
in terms of type Theory but that's type
Theory with a lid put on what its
capabilities are
um and that lid doesn't allow you to do
arbitrary computation
um but that prevents that that's what
allows you to do the analysis that lets
you use it to say in this piece of
compiled code this will be that we can
convert this particular you know X is
always can be represented at the Machine
level in this particular way
okay so in any case types were another
kind of uh structuring concept and types
got more elaborate
um then
you know I would say that the uh the
story of sort of how to organize large
pieces of code I was just going to say
that I I kind of think that a number of
ideas have been really
bizarrely missed in the history of of
typical programming one is symbolic
computation and this idea that you can
have an X that just stands for itself or
a thing that represents a city or
something and that that kind of a thing
which if you start saying let's talk
about data types that x what type is
that X well it isn't a type it just
stands for itself and it can be a city
it can be an image it can be all sorts
of things you don't have to say and in
modern language for example we've sort
of uh abstracted things beyond the level
of types
um and we don't have to be talking about
is the symbolic expression of this type
or that type it's just a symbolic
expression and from the structure of the
expression you can say things about what
you might consider it to mean like it's
a you can think of this as an image or
we can think of this as a piece of audio
or something like this
um and I and I think that uh you know
sometimes people have been chasing the
wrong kinds of things in terms of sort
of how to structure large programs I
think one of the things that's very
interesting with with Wolfram language
because it's a symbolic language uh
where uh sort of uh everything is about
Transformations on symbolic Expressions
so any fragment of code there is a
meaningful thing that you can feed to
that fragment of code and what the
fragment of code produces as output it's
just a symbolic expression you don't
need to put it in kind of a harness to
say oh I'm going to structure this data
in this way and bottle these things in
memory in this form and then at the end
I want it to print something there's no
need to say oh print something you just
handed back a symbolic expression and
then in the usual notebook interface
there's some display mechanism for that
symbolic expression but the main point
is it's just a symbolic expression that
you can then go and compute with
elsewhere and so that you know when it
comes to things like debugging the fact
is you can take you can sort of take
your program apart and all the pieces
actually operate as Standalone things
that's an important idea and I think in
um uh you know some of what's happened
in terms of the structuring of large
programs uh has partly to do with the
fact that there are you know there start
to be groups of people that work on them
and there's you know it all gets
enmeshed with Source Control Systems uh
you know the the idea of source control
things like git and so on in modern
times that whole idea is very old
um what is it the uh the patch system I
remember back when I first used uh
online uh where you didn't have card
decks where you could actually have your
program in
um uh stored uh online and then you
would submit versions of the program
in some very bizarre way and this was
true even in the mid-1970s
um you would have this this patching
mechanism where you'd say here's my
original code and I'm going to add some
patches to that original code and the
patch thing is what I now want to submit
and I'm now a little bit not remembering
how that all worked but I think there
was a already a thing called RCS I think
which was a patching system for code
um and so this idea of sort of making
differences in code and taking your
original program and making patches to
it that's a very very old idea but that
got much more structured with these kind
of shared server-based
um kinds of mechanisms I suppose those
things were server based as well because
they were on time shared systems with
with Central Computers and so on but um
in any case that that's some
uh yeah so I mean when it comes to
uh you know when talk about design
patterns and so on for for languages you
know one of the things that as a
language designer you know my goal is if
there is a thing people always want to
do just give it a name and have it be a
function in the language and then that's
how people can do it rather than saying
you know by the time you say here's an
idiom that you should learn that is a
pattern for how to do this
um that's sort of a a a a you know that
was a step not taken by the language
designer now sometimes when you do
language design it's important to have a
name for this lump of computational work
and if if common language does not
provide you a reasonable name for that
then it can be difficult and sometimes
you know at a slow rate I introduce kind
of completely new names for things that
are you know where you just have to
learn this word because it's a New
Concept
um and you know but you don't get to do
that at a very high rate
now you know I will also say that I
think there are uh you know these
different patterns for for programming
in general uh from sort of the the I
would say functional programming is you
know in in wolfen language I would say
there's people do a tiny amount of
procedural programming that's very quite
rare it's mostly functional programming
or pattern-based programming
pattern-based programming is all about
you've got a symbolic expression and you
want to transform it and that's kind of
an idea for programming it's super
powerful not so popular
um it was something that was in some of
the early string manipulation languages
like snowball for example had ideas like
that but it's really a very powerful
idea and it's something that in a sense
is the generalization of sort of apply a
function to things because in in
symbolic Transformations what you're
doing is you're saying there's a pattern
that is a class of expressions and they
all get transformed this way and one
particular class of expressions are
things like f of x blank that represents
a function f with sort of any expression
inside it gets transformed in that way
but this sort of idea of functional
programming
um which is kind of the uh you know you
can trace that back to things like
combinators from 1920 things like Lambda
calculus from 1935 and this idea that
there is a uh it's a bit like a
mathematical function but it is a
computational analog of that in which
you're kind of having this thing that
sort of eats an input and produces a
result and that you kind of think about
computation as being a sequence of of
such functions sort of encapsulated as
the only thing that happens it's kind of
the opposite end of the world from
Fortran common blocks where there's this
big Global thing and you're you're sort
of plucking things out of this Global uh
you know Global pile of of data it's
rather it's very encapsulated the thing
just has sort of one mouth that it eats
data into and that's and and then it it
uh you know then it produces its results
and so on by the way I mean in in very
modern times you know one of the things
I'm interested in is generalizing those
set of ideas into the sort of
multi-computational world and that
relates a lot to uh
things in you know higher category
Theory and all these other other kinds
of approaches but that gets us way off
track
um
the uh
the primalities is commenting that they
think algo was the first to have uh uh
language to have a prison I think that's
right I mean recursion just to be clear
the history of recursion itself
was
you know in a sense you can point to
things like the Fibonacci sequence uh
you know defined in terms of rabbits in
previous years by uh by old Fibonacci in
in 12 1200 ish
um that's sort of an example of
recursion in some sense it's sort of
thinking about a new thing in terms of
older versions of the same thing and the
same that occurred in recurrence
relations those were extensively handled
in the 1800s and things you know people
like Bool wrote books about difference
equations which was about recurrences
and so on so as a mathematical concept
you know F of n depends on F of n minus
one and F of n minus two and whatever
else that was a pretty known thing uh in
the 1800s and so on then when people
were trying to sort of formalize
mathematics
uh one of the key ideas oh I should have
said one of the one of the ways that
recursion was used was in proof by
induction
so you know proof by induction says you
can prove it for the case of N and then
sorry you can if you can prove it for n
then induction means you can prove it
for n plus one you can jump from n to n
plus one and there's a base case for one
for example and therefore mathematical
induction says therefore you can prove
it for all cases and so for example in
the piano axioms for arithmetic
developed by Giuseppe piano in 1880s or
so
um the induction Axiom is the most
sophisticated Axiom in piano arithmetic
the the assumption that if you the thing
I just described if you can prove it for
if you can go from n to n plus one and
you've got the base case covered then
it's true for all n
um so that was sort of an example of
recursion and then when
when people like Hilbert around 1900
were trying to sort of formalize what is
mathematics made of one of the things
that they introduced was this idea of
primitive recursion the idea of any
function that you can Define in
mathematics can be defined in terms of
previous values of that function more or
less
and that'll work very fine until Wilhelm
ackermann who was a student of Hilbert's
discovered this thing called the
Ackerman function I think around 1920
which was a function that grows too
quickly to be primitive recursive it
doesn't just look back at its values it
has this mu operator that has the
equivalent of something where you know
that that's in general recursion that
comes later with with girdle and so on
but the ackermann function uh well the
argument function is basically the
function where you are starting off with
one plus one plus one plus one and times
makes
um uh
makes n then n a bunch of times makes uh
your that's multiplication you go from
you know addition to multiplication then
you do repeated multiplication that's
Powers you do repeated Powers that's
titration or power Towers or something
the Ackerman function is the
parameterized function that says you're
going in that hierarchy you know it has
two arguments and one of them is what um
uh
tours at three arguments I think for the
original argument function might be
three arguments that says which level of
this hierarchy are you at and then what
up what fun what values are you
operating on
um and so that function could be shown
not to be part of recursive and so that
kind of blew out the idea of of of uh
primitive recursion would be the end of
the story and then good will introduce
General recursion
Etc but this idea that recursion was an
interesting construct and concept was
something that had certainly bubbled up
in the world of mathematical logic now
it's worth remembering that many of the
things that have bubbled up in the world
of mathematical logic were not really
used in programming languages maybe
algol tried to use some of them but uh
you know a lot of the lessons from
combinators about sort of symbolic
Transformations and so on really were
not I would say seriously used I mean
I've tried to seriously use these things
um I don't think they've been very
widely widely used
uh
let's see
uh probably some comments on this hold
on one second
um
David Brown is asking have Julius set
some for two sets played a significant
role in the development of computer
programming languages I think absolutely
not
um so far as I know Gaston Julia
who is a mathematician in the first few
Decades of the of the 20th century
French mathematician
um introduced this idea of Julia sets
that was a time when okay so this field
of dynamical systems theory let's see
there was a convergence of a few
different things
there have been a lot of work in
Celestial mechanics that had led to sort
of the idealization of a you know
solving a differential equation and
seeing what the solution set looked like
that had led people like Point array to
introduce topology and so on meanwhile
there was a bunch of work being done on
group Theory and on I'm not sure I know
this history that well
uh
the end result was that this notion of
iterated iterations like take a number Z
complex number Z and replace it by Z
squared plus a constant that was a thing
that people started looking at in um
around 1900 and I'm not sure I
completely know why okay we're looking
at that
um
I think it was some well I'm not sure
um but Julia was part of that and he
produced really some quite nice pictures
as I recall of the sets that you get
from looking at those kinds of
iterations
well
but no big mathematics got built from
that at that time
I think this was the theory of
functional iteration actually this was a
that's right I think this had been a
branch of um uh sort of the the notion
of iterating functions was something
that was sort of a separate prong of
just a thing that people investigated
so
uh but I think it was a kind of dried up
the field of dynamical systems theory
took off in a slightly different way in
the 1930s and so on then what really
made Julia sets and such like I think
famous was Ben Ray mandelbrot in the
1970s uh sort of developing this idea of
fractals of nested self-similar patterns
and so on of which Julius sets are an
example and I think that's what really
brought them to prominence and so far as
I know they didn't really have a um uh I
think it's a very distant you know
Gaston Julia I don't think had anything
to do with anything that turned into
programming languages I think he was a
pretty traditional uh kind of calculus
analysis oriented mathematician
um in in the first part of the 20th
century to my to my knowledge I might be
wrong about that but that's that's what
I know
um
the uh
let's see
um
Rift tracks is commenting about
um structure of computer languages and
um you know one of the things that's
interesting about languages is
there are very interesting abstract
ideas
and when you have learned a lot of
concrete examples of things and then
somebody tells you that abstract idea
you say Aha and you start being able to
go off and use it but for most people
when you first present them with and
here's an abstract idea here's an
anonymous function here's a some higher
order you know function construct it's
like why are you doing that that just
doesn't make any sense but by the time
you've seen many examples where somebody
then tells you the rule for how to
generalize it does make sense and that's
a you know it's a thing you have to
learn it's a sort of a thing to learn
about computation just like you might
learn things about I don't know English
you probably probably wouldn't be very
useful to try and start teaching
somebody grammar and saying you know
there are verbs and there are nouns and
there are sentences put together in this
way and so on if you're still
you know learning to speak your first
words and so on you don't really you're
not really ready to say oh yeah now I
can see how sentences are put together
and I think it's the same kind of thing
with sort of ideas about about languages
let's see
uh
very different question here from guiel
did 18th century engineers and Craftsmen
make use of Newtonian mechanics
did they make use of sort of the
Paradigm of Newtonian mechanics it's an
interesting question
I know that
uh you know if you're going to build a
cathedral you want it to not fall down
and you know the stone masons and the
Freemasons and so on developed a lot of
knowledge about how to make a cathedral
that's not going to fall down
and I think uh were they explicitly
using Force diagrams and so on I don't
think so I think they knew certain
patterns that would work I mean it's
sort of reminiscent of what happened in
something like logic you know when
Aristotle originally invented logic he
did it as here are some abstract
patterns that kind of describe the form
of various arguments that people make
and my guess is I don't know for sure my
guess is that in a lot of early
engineering it was kind of like here is
a somewhat abstract pattern that
abstracts from the specifics of this
particular Bridge or this particular
buttress of some Cathedral or something
to something a little bit more General
but it's still a pattern it's still this
is how it works it's not there is a
generator there is a set of mathematical
or formal principles from which you can
generate all these things it's rather
here's a pattern follow it
um I think that there was work done in
the early 1800s people were interested
in trusses uh you know kind of trust
structures of you know cross beams and
so on and how would you make something
that was for example a stable trust
where for example if the if the members
of the trusts were were rigid with
respect to let's say compression or or
shearing or something like that that you
would be able to but that but they were
pivoted at joints how would you make
something that would be rigid so for
example you know a triangle is rigid a
tetrahedron is rigid a a um uh let's see
a cube is not rigid right the um you can
you take that right there are many
structures you basically have to have
triangles in tetrahedra I think in
structures to have
um to have something which is rigid so
if you can pivot the ends you know
clearly if you have a square it's not
rigid you you can pivot it and it'll
squash into a you know into a
parallelogram or some other
quadrilateral or whatever
um and so the question was if you have
rigid members but with sort of floppy
joints what would be uh you know what
kinds of structures could you build that
would be rigid and that's a thing that I
think in the early 1800s uh and probably
the late 1700s was kind of a thing
um
that was that people were thinking about
and I think there you don't really have
to use Newtonian mechanics as such
because really more of a kind of
geometry type question what structures
will be rigid
um in terms of when people started to
use you know start to really think about
forces and and actually do actual
computations it's an interesting
question because people were Building
Bridges and things like that and I don't
know you know did Gustav Eiffel when he
built the Eiffel Tower which is you know
the Eiffel Tower was a bridge demo so to
speak you know with with some pieces
that are like parts of bridges
um was not intended to be a permanent
structure but has turned out to be
um but uh you know did
did Eiffel for example
um you know do people like that really
do computations of sort of uh you know
there's this Force here and and that's
how this will work or was it more rule
of thumb kind of engineering I I'm not
sure about the answer to that
um I think by the time well let me see
uh you know early things like steam
engines and so on absolutely wasn't a
theory there I mean that was you know
what would you what was the Motive Power
of heat so to speak I've just been
recently been looking at this stuff that
was Sadi Kano in the 1820s was wrote
this book about the Motive Power of heat
in French
um and uh you know the big question
actually the interesting thing sadikano
did was he said oh there have been
people like James watts and all these
people who've made up steam engines and
they've tried to make their steam
engines more efficient by having you
know this valve opens and this cold
water pours in here and then this
happens and then that happens but what's
the sort of theoretical what's the
idealized engine it's kind of like the
turing machine of steam so to speak
what's the idealized engine like and how
efficient might it be but that wasn't
Newtonian mechanics at all that was that
was an argument in the end that would
turn into thermodynamics
um those are quite
different kind of structure and
um where were the first Engineering
Systems that were really making use of
serious we can solve a differential
equation type type stories hmm I'm not
sure I know the answer to that uh let's
see
um
you know I I don't think the Wright
brothers were doing that stuff they were
worrying about questions of control and
it was much more rule of thumb
engineering I would say I I do think
that um uh
uh I really don't know I mean but
certainly by
the time of World War One there were
things that were being computed all the
time
but I'm not sure how much there was
before that I mean in in
um I don't know it's a good question I I
should find out I don't know the answer
to that
um
let's see
maybe a couple more here
um
Parker asks why is it that Isaac Newton
spent so much of his time trying to
prove theological ideas
well I don't know so much about Newton's
theology
um I think he was a little bit of an
outlier
um in in sort of the the tradition of
the time but you know theology was the
prevailing intellectual framework of
those times
and uh you know I would say that that
at any given time there are certain sort
of prevailing cultural kind of uh
um
um you know norms and patterns of
thinking and theology was a big one I
mean theology had been the dominant
place where intellectual uh efforts got
put
for a couple of thousand years
um or you know versions of theology
um and and so when you look at kind of
the uh some of the things I've done
recently about the rouliad and and the
idea of sort of foundations of physics
and Mathematics and so on the questions
that come up there about sort of why
does the universe exist and these the
questions about our role as an observer
in the universe and so on many of those
questions are sort of almost logical
questions or if you asked who's asked
these questions before the answer is the
theologians ask these questions and they
ask questions about you know what was if
if there's sort of an ultimate
everything to the universe what would
that be like and what would
characteristics would it have what could
you deduce from the role of us humans
relative to the everything and so on
there are lots of kinds of thinking that
existed the theological thinking that I
I would say are now coming back as
things which you know after we're sort
of we've worked through the kind of
mathematical Paradigm of science some of
these foundational questions sort of
reappear but they were the you know they
were the pattern of thinking at the time
of Newton I mean it was sort of what
Newton was doing you know in his
original principia Mathematica for
mechanics you know that was very much
modeled and Euclid it was very much
modeled on sort of let's have an
aximatization of the ideas of how
mechanics works and you know when it
came to thinking about other things in
the world you know theology was it was a
dominant uh sort of basis for these
kinds of things now now Newton had
um again I don't know in much detail
about his theological work
um I I do know that he had some sort of
side interests and so on like one of the
things he was curious about is he was
doing uh you know things about astronomy
and he wanted to date
things that were
um
uh sort of ancient astronomical events
ancient eclipses you know and and and so
he went back and and you know in the in
the Bible you know it'll describe some I
don't actually know if there are
eclipses described but wouldn't be
surprised if there were
um at least by by implication
um but then so what Newton wanted to do
is he wanted to figure out you know that
Eclipse that thales you know famously
was supposed to have predicted in some
that caused what the Greeks and Persians
or something to just sort of forget
about the Battle because something too
funky was happening when there was a
total solar eclipse I don't know what
the true story there is but there's
there is sort of uh you know uh versions
of that
um but so Newton wanted to know when was
that eclipse and so his very last book I
have a copy of it actually it's not one
of his most famous books it's it's
called the chronology of ancient
kingdoms and it's an attempt to go back
and understand when did those things
actually happen it's not particularly
successful I mean it doesn't get things
that well correct but it's sort of an
interesting um uh version of that and
you know I think Newton uh you know at
the time when Newton was working you
know he was a professor in Cambridge
there weren't very many professors he
was the Lucasian professor of
mathematics in Cambridge I think Mr
Lucas who endowed that was just you know
Newton was not the uh like incumbent
number three or something of that of
that professorship and it was a rare
thing to have a gig we just got to do so
professor in all your time
um and and he got that but but Cambridge
was a a school that was primarily
training people to become uh you know to
go into the church and so
it was certainly a thing that you had to
be sort of uh you know involved with and
aware of the whole kind of theological
story and I and I think probably you
know people would have been shocked by
Newton's you know I don't know
trinitarian I forget what his the exact
details of his his uh religious setup
were but I think that you kind of had
that was the ambient environment in
which you operated in the University at
the time I mean I people might say uh uh
rather perhaps uncharitably I don't know
that you know in in some universities
today there's a certain kind of uh uh
sort of cultural belief system
environment where everybody has to
believe in this and that and the other
thing and you know if you're not uh oh I
don't know you know if you if you don't
believe enough in
uh you know social cause XYZ or whatever
then uh you know then you can't really
you know then you'll get you'll get uh
ejected from the University as being you
know too shocking and in Newton's time
if you didn't believe in you know this
or that aspect of some theological uh
thing the same thing was likely to
happen so I think that that Newton was
probably studying that
um I you know it's uh you know partly
but for those kinds of reasons
uh
let's see
um
okay Lawrence asked and I should stop
soon here but but um when will Moore's
Law expire uh
I was talking about I haven't seen this
particular announcement about a four
nanometer technology
um so
you know Gordon Moore
uh
founder of Intel had sort of um uh made
this statement you know computers are
going to get what was it twice as fast
every 18 months or something
um and for quite a while that was
happening
and then it stopped last decade or more
that hasn't been what's happened
um I mean the you know I know this with
painful reality because when we first
built wolf from alpha for example I was
assuming that that curve would continue
and so certain kinds of things it's like
look don't worry about how fast this is
right now because in a couple of years
it's going to be faster and turns out
that didn't happen that way
um because there was kind of a limit
reached where in terms of an individual
core in a computer that's you know
that's how fast it runs now you know
there's been a progressive speeding up
of uh you know the clock speeds two
gigahertz or something as a typical kind
of clock speed today it has been for a
while
um that hasn't been dramatically
increasing in speed I think what's been
being done is the gradual tweaking of
sort of semiconductor technology and the
reducing capacitance and so on so that
you can increase the clock speed
reducing feature size so you can put
more features onto a silicon uh
you know onto a chip that doesn't have
imperfections in it and so on doesn't
have Crystal defects and all that kind
of thing and then ways to work around
those Crystal defects and so on there's
been sort of this gradual uh thing going
down you know five nanometer processors
are sort of a common thing today and and
you know you have to sort of build a
whole new Factory often to support sort
of getting things as clean and perfect
as you need to achieve a sort of a
greater level of smallness in in
photography and so on
um the uh
and I mean essentially the uh now the
question is are there other Technologies
quite different technologies that you
can use that don't just involve you know
etching channels out of out of silicon
and the answer is undoubtedly yes and in
fact sort of some part of the quantum
Computing world has nothing to do with
Quantum but it does have to do with
using other physical methods to to
support computation and an old idea was
to use Josephson Junction
superconducting Joseph's injunctions to
do computation their ideas about using
photons to do computation Optical
Computing both of those sort of have
their brand is often Quantum Computing
today but ultimately they're just a
different kind of uh approach to using
uh sort of physical things to do
computation and certainly my own
principle of computational equivalence
and so on suggests that you can make
computers out of almost anything the
question is really what's convenient to
engineer computers out of and I I happen
to think there are lots of things things
that you could engineer computers out of
that are different from the things that
have traditionally been used
but I think the thing that's really
happened with Computing is you know
insofar as our speed increases it's
because things went more parallel you
know what was oh you go through an array
and you do an operation on each element
in turn becomes a GPU that's an array
processor where you have separate
Hardware to operate on each element of
the array and you can just do the whole
thing in parallel or where you're doing
things where you say you know
speculative execution of instructions
where you have your CPU and it's saying
well let me go ahead and and I don't
know which way this this if statement's
going to Branch this conditional is
going to Branch but I'm just going to
try and you know pre-compute what
happens on both of those branches and
I'm going to pre-fetch the things from
memory that I might need those kinds of
tricks are being used to try and speed
things up even within the context of
existing software one of the big
dividing lines is can you take an
existing large Software System that's
ultimately written in like C or or
nowadays in something like llvm that's
kind of low level generic machine
language type type system that lots of
compilers Target can you take something
written in those kinds of languages and
can you run it sort of Raw on your
computer or do you have to re-architect
your program in order to have it to be
able to run on on your computer and I
think one of the things that's been sort
of a challenge for gpus Is that in a
sense the one of the things that wasn't
obvious they were going to work out that
way is you have to you know it's
particular pieces of code that are
specially programmed to run on gpus it
isn't oh let's just take our generic
program and somehow magically have it
run faster on GPU no that's not what
happens it's not what's happening when
you make things that run in parallel you
usually have you have to think about the
fact oh I want to run this in parallel
you know when I use in Wilson language
we for a long time had parallel
computation Primitives and you know I do
a parallel map or something I'm I'm
running in parallel across a couple
hundred computers let's say but I have
to think to do that and there are some
you know internal operations that
automatically do it but it's not
something where it's sort of you just
take existing software and just say oh
now I'm going to put it on the magic
parallel machine it's going to go faster
um so there's sort of a question of
whether there's a whole other level of
software that could be built that is
sort of born uh sort of more parallel
born more able to take advantage of what
physics can offer and the fact that in
physics there can be things that are in
different places in space that are
running at the same time I mean it could
be the case that you know physics was
just purely sequential but it's not
physics has built-in sort of parallelism
across space and so on and so the
question is you know can you can you
fundamentally take advantage of that in
a in a sense our whole multi-computation
initiative is a bit about that although
it goes even a further level which is
when there are multiple Paths of History
you could be following all those
different pods even though they're
inconsistent with each other even though
there are different branches you could
take and those kind of lead you to
different places in branchial space just
like you can lay out computations and
and physical space with different sort
of elements of arrays and things so you
can lay out computations in branchial
space where you're sort of taking the
different branches in the conditionals
and so on and those represent this sort
of set of possibilities and so kind of
um the uh you know that that say
it's sort of an interesting thing to
kind of think about how computation can
get sort of decomposed in these
different ways and I think one of the
things I've been realizing recently is
this kind of time-like computation where
you do a computation you take the result
of that computation you do another
computation it's a sequence of things
through time so there's sort of a causal
dependence chain that goes from one
computation to the next to the next
then there's sort of space-like
Separation where you have things which
can happen at sort of separately in
different places in space all sort of
parallel in time and then there's
branch-like separation where you can
have things which are sort of happening
as different branches of possibilities
and which can for example merge in the
future because both branches lead to the
same result in the end or maybe they
don't merge in the future but but this
kind of space like time like space like
Branch like time-like separation I think
is a useful way to think about
computation and we're just so that
people have been doing some sort of
space like computation with array
processing forever and ever and you know
more from language for example we have
the kind of notion of listable functions
and so on which just sort of take as one
gulp this sort of parallel thing to be
done across lots of different elements I
would say branch-like separation is much
less well understood in in programming I
mean that's really the story you know
sort of when you have these different
brands launches and they don't converge
to the same thing when they do converge
to the same thing that's sort of an
eventual consistency story when they
don't it's kind of what we call a race
condition you know it matters which one
actually happens first because that's
what determines what what really
happened there are two branches of
possibilities and but there's still a
really happened notion and so then the
question is you know how do you in a in
a kind of organized way think about this
sort of the different branches of what
might happen and that's what um one of
my current projects is uh looking at
sort of our multi-computational Paradigm
that's Arisen from the physics project
and where we talk about different
observers of this sort of set of
branching possibilities and it's kind of
partly a story of quantum mechanics
partly story of Relativity those ideas
get immediately imported into
distributed computing and that's a
coming soon attraction I hope
all right
uh
you know I think um
Gordon is commenting that um uh
that computers nowadays are more
powerful
uh powerful enough for the average user
you know what's so strange about that is
that you know like the computer that I
have sitting in front of me right here
is you know it's a laptop and it's kind
of a generic laptop and you know
sometimes running these live streams the
things fan jumps you know starts up and
it's like really straining and it's like
really I mean that's you know what's
happening is that there are always these
things like video for example video is
is still straining to computers in some
ways now you know the interesting
question is
some other things like for example when
it comes to text it's hard to strain
your computer with text because you know
humans only read text at a certain rate
and you know we have a certain built-in
time scale for that when it comes to
audio it's become pretty challenging to
strain your computer with audio because
you know humans only ingest audio at a
certain rate you know we can go up to I
don't know 20 something kilohertz or
something of of you know our ears
depending on how how agile your ears are
maybe you can reach 25 kilohertz or
something but it's still low data rates
for uh you know for a display our eyes
are more in the gigahertz type range
um in terms of uh
um is that right we've got 10 million
node fibers and we've got yes that's
right
um and we've got um uh you know some
number of tens of times per second
um of of data that that um is
transmitted through our visual system
and so that's still a bit of a strain
for computers of today it probably won't
be for that much longer and it will be
the case that sort of things of direct
human relevance will start dropping
below what you know becoming what easy
for computers and the question is well
what other things are there that you
know what what what then becomes the
difficult stuff for computers now you
know as somebody who's interested in
science for example there are always
difficult things that I have for
computers to do but you know there are
things that one can imagine like for
example creating you know in in game
like environments or in in Virtual
Worlds you know creating the whole sort
of simulating saying well actually yes I
mean one thing that's always going to be
hard is simulating physics because and
simulating what happens in the world
because after all the actual computation
that's going on in the world and we now
think we have sort of a fundamental
Theory of physics and we know that
physics is ultimately computational all
the way down but the amount of
computation that's being done in every
you know cubic centimeter of of universe
is very huge it's huge compared to what
our computers could possibly do
necessarily so because our computers are
ultimately made of that same stuff that
makes the universe so it's not
surprising that the computers under our
Direct Control have less that they can
do than than the sort of intrinsic
computation of the universe but you know
when it comes to simulating things that
happen in the universe that's a thing
that's always going to strain our
computers now then the question is well
what about the things we care about that
are happening in the universe and that
becomes a more more nuanced question of
how far you have to go with computers
now you know people say well what about
like things like quantum mechanics well
in our models we kind of understand how
quantum mechanics works and it's this
kind of multi-threaded sort of process
where
um where in the end the thing we as
observers notice is just some
combination of slice across all those
different threads but the way the
quantum mechanics is working inside it's
all those different threads and that's
again for the universe it's just what it
does but for our computers that can be a
challenging thing whether it matters is
is unclear whether it actually by the
time you as an observer are cutting
across all those threads and measuring
something that you can sequentially
experience because our experiences are
sequential whereas quantum mechanics is
running all these different threads in
parallel when we come to experience
things in the world our experiences
fundamentally an experience of a
sequence of of things having happened so
we're sort of we're cons we're we're
we're pulling down that sort of quantum
parallelism and and whether whether it
ultimately matters that there was that
parallelism inside that's an interesting
question of sort of the the the sort of
the the the shadow of quantumness and
how much how how well that's cost on on
things uh sort of uh once we once we
actually observe them
well anyway so I think um
this question of of what will be the
places where uh you know where sort of
will always have more computation to do
certainly there are questions in science
where you know the fact science is sort
of an endless Frontier that's kind of
guaranteed by computational
irreducibility and undecidability that
there will be questions in science where
the only way to know the answer is just
to keep Computing and there will always
be surprises and that sort of drives One
Direction of you always need more
computation another one is the physical
universe is you know you'll never be
able to get down to the level of all the
computation it does but there are parts
of it that we might care about that
still need a lot more computation so I
think there will be places where where
there's still sort of more computation
to be done although there are certainly
places where it drops below you know
computers are fast enough that for any
human purposes you know you click it and
yes it did take 100 milliseconds to
respond but you'll never notice because
we're just humans with our a sort of
human uh sort of uh rate of of brain
processing and so on and and it doesn't
make much difference if you are you know
that 100 milliseconds let's cut it down
to 50 milliseconds okay great nobody's
going to notice
um but still there are things where
there's enough bulk of computation that
it does make a big difference
all right well we should probably wrap
up there thanks for lots of interesting
topics and I see many more that I didn't
have a chance to cover today
um and uh you know I'm going to make a
small pitch because I you know I I'm
about to dive into another kind of
historical investigation that I will
write some stuff about this one is about
the history of thermodynamics a very
interesting and Confused history which I
actually thought I understood but have
discovered new things about but uh you
know I do write a fair amount about uh
and have written a fair amount about the
history of Science and Technology and
you can find that on my writings website
um there's a category for historical
perspectives and uh I think some of
those things are pretty fun to read and
I encourage people to take a look at
them some of them I've even done as kind
of spoken podcast type things and uh
that should be interested people think
that those are a good idea uh give us
some feedback about that because
um uh it's pretty easy for me to read
those things and usually I I embellish
them of it as I'm reading them because I
think of other stuff as I'm as I'm
reading through what I wrote before
um and uh be interested in no other
people would like to see more of those
or hear more of those
all right I should wrap up for now
thanks very much and uh bye for now